Outbrain network which monitors
thousands and thousands of websites they
were tracking who was talking about
Syria and when and they were comparing
it to the Miley Cyrus twerking fiasco so
first let's watch miley cyrus twerk
Bobby Blair yes
don't
I mean someone needs to invade America
so to deal with our crap too you know
we're not that perfect okay so they did
this study comparing what was going on
on social media that was happening the
exact same time that Obama was first
starting to talk about a military strike
in Syria so they monitored thousands of
websites there were in the three days
surrounding Miley's VMA performance and
this is right when the Syria thing was
breaking there were eight thousand
stories about miley cyrus twerking and
about 20,000 on Syria okay that that
seems pretty good right that seems okay
uh interestingly though the day after
the vmas the miley cyrus stories
accounted for twelve percent of all us
page views and cereal only accounted for
one so even though there were basically
three times as many serious stories way
way more people 12 times exactly we're
reading about miley cyrus and the
twerking okay so here you go these are
this is global content which was one
smiling which one is violating do we
even have to go into this any further
I'm pretty sure yeah the pink one is
Miley and we should have had a twerking
Miley gift or something there so yeah I
mean we don't have to get into the
specifics of the numbers they're bonkers
way more people were tweeting about
Miley facebooking about Miley sharing
links about Miley all that stuff uh is
this just sort of work we're Rome you
know like we got it so good and we
complain about everything all the time
but you know some bad stuff happens in
Syria but at the end of the day if a
former Disney star is rubbing her butt
against the father from growing pains
crotch ya can't is that just more game
chemical weapons twerking chemical
weapons yeah you got your gonna put on
the twerking you're gonna put on the
twerking yeah that's how r us how that's
how we roll that's how we deal with I
mean this graph doesn't surprise me at
all I mean not even the least bit I mean
it's no I mean also I mean it's so
ridiculous that Miley Cyrus's out doing
Syria news story ah but you know
everyone again and we go back to the
topic
everyone is so sick of these like world
politics of just like just war after war
in this country and invading this
country in this and so people just like
you know what I just I want I wants
miley cyrus i want the pain to go away
yeah you know what maybe maybe i'll be
apologetic because i'm the first always
say and i think a lot of viewers don't
like it I said we're generally a stupid
country but in this particular this
particular scenario i think it's the
phenomenon of the 12 year old now
everyone's on the internet i have almost
a two-year-old son the boy knows how to
use an ipad like he's like he's 25 and
he's like gifts went and goes he finds
what he wants on youtube and the boy
can't read obviously yeah he uh but he
knows what he wants and he finds it so
at 12 we have that we saw the audience
there and at the VMAs and they go crazy
I mean we adults here we go what the
[ __ ] and there was so this is sort of
yeah yo the young people are consuming
this stuff and it's like when Bieber
tweets a smiley face and it gets 30
thousand retweets in a second versus
something that Hillary Clinton like me
and what always notices from is you know
this horrible kid movies I'm not some of
the shreks and the monsters inks and and
the new ones out the airplanes in the
cars those are good is right but there's
really bad ones like say snow dogs that
that you you see the pre's ago this
looks absolutely horrible who was gonna
watch this they make the most money
every movie because kids go in and kids
go and 1c movies I got so funny then
they take their father then they take
the mother then they take the baby then
they take big sister they take their
friends and all these ticket sales rack
up for these horror movies because
there's 23 fart jokes in ago I got many
by the product this were all the money
goes because they have to keep pushing
more everyone does everything for their
kids and you get in that and they hit
all these side or went over again that's
a really good point this makes me feel a
lot better about the graph because I'm
thinking that that graph is all adults
and I'm like oh god no I'm things right
but what does your serious in future no
it doesn't bode well for the future but
then again you know twelve-year-old
third year old what they're consuming
the
going to be very uh excited about
talking about chemical weapon yeah all
right well we actually have another
graph for ya and it's not just America
that has this major disproportioned
problem okay so this is broken down by
country so you can see the u.s. is crazy
we just love Miley more than everybody
else but it's it's completely uh bonkers
here what's happening the Philippines
Australia UK everyone's more than double
basically the only country that they
paid more attention to Syria than to
Miley Cyrus out of these 10 or so was
Israel that might be because they're
next door they're buying can you know
buying gas masks Russia was like within
the margin of error because they're the
hero so that they had to really pay
attention to both so does this give us a
little hope because again we think
everything's about Americans there's a
little hope to be seen in there that the
Spanish you know they're they're
twerking too I think this is actually
the opposite of a little hope check the
woods this graph actually made me
horribly depressed oakley the entire
world is excited to see miley cyrus back
it up but no one really is like a Assad
and the weapons and then but on the put
on the twerking the twerking do you
think we need this kind of escapism
though there's only we talked about this
in the news all the time but we do need
some of this stuff to just be able to
function right maybe I'm the bad guy but
I go home and watch stupid TV that's it
and listen to a president obama speak a
listen to senators and congressmen speak
all day and analyze everything they talk
about and have to go and dispel what
they said in the remember what they said
back in april to make sure that this
[ __ ] didn't go wrong that way and hold a
my brain is full of first a lot of liars
and you have to really critically think
about what they're saying as they're
saying it in there loyally terms I get
home I'm like okay what is the dumbest
thing I can watch right now because I
need some some escape so where do you go
for dumb ISM cuz I'm guessing it's not
Miley twerk well I'll go first to sports
it's awesomely not done but it's some
escape that's my main thing but I'm you
know then next comes on is the
basketball wives and I don't watch The
Real Housewives but because my
girlfriend does it's on and next thing
I'm like how does this [ __ ] do that I
can't believe she you know and i'm like
i can't i can't like I don't get into
enough to watch every episode when it's
on
I just sink in and like yeah sure let's
go for it yeah maybe the more bullshitty
politics becomes the more craptastic the
reality TV has to come to capture sounds
all the ghost shows them so I'm gonna
come back to your question the celebrity
ghost stories do stuff on bio I survived
although those are real stories yeah
it's like sensationally like that guy
almost got killed how do you get out of
it I've been watching these mountain men
these guys there's something else really
these guys there's nothing there that's
what do you do for the for the escapist
crazy sports junkie and I will watch I
will watch absolute like just hours like
yesterday I did the mexico-us men's
soccer match into rachel maddow so I'm
like all right I got I got I got my
soccer into Rachel don't I mean but I'd
so yeah it is you try to balance it and
you know you're writing and I have to
you know just to do stand-up comedy
after do you have to consume much so
much news and politics well I love to
talk about that anyway obviously but uh
but then yeah then I'll just watch
SportsCenter for hours and nine for nine
it was like this great documentary
series every Tuesday the summer about
female athletes oh I think now I think
I've watched everything three times like
I just can't I can't stop yeah well as
you guys probably know my balance is
watching copious amounts of the Golden
Girls although nine out of ten times I'm
watching and I'm thinking what would
Dorothy think about Syria really